welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and coming out of the multiverse of
green goblin gliding gladness that was
spider-man nowhere home one of the
biggest questions that you guys have had
for all of us here at new rockstars is
why the hell did that venom symbiote get
left behind in the mcu like what is so
special about this black goo on the bar
that makes it strong enough to resist
one of the most powerful spells
performed by earth's sorcerer supreme
well my beautiful nerd babies i think i
actually do know the mcu scientific
explanation as to why this happened and
i believe that it was actually teased to
us in the post-credits scene of venom
let there be carnage so let's find out
how together okay so remember when eddie
and venom are on their honeymoon at the
end of venom 2 and they start talking
about trying new and exciting things
together and then venom says this 80
billion light years of hive knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain wait time out light years
venom light years uh last time i checked
a light year is a unit of measuring
space rangers and the distance light
travels in space over the course of a
year so why oh why did venom use a unit
of distance like it was a unit of time
that sounds weird like that's literally
like saying you have 75 yards of
experience in microsoft word during a
job interview like that don't make
no sense unless he was actually talking
about a unit of time the light years as
supposed to say i don't know the dark
years during the dark world the period
of time when the universe was dark
before the birth of all the light and
the stars with the big bay however just
because the light life that we know of
did not exist yet during this stage of
the mcu it does not mean that this dark
universe did not have vitamin d
deficient dark beings just chilling out
accident relaxing all cold like dark
beings tend to do i'm always just
chilling man talking about frogman i'm
talking about flexo yo flexo i love
flexo you know beings like malekith and
the dark elves and i'm speculating all
the aliens affiliated with thanos's
black order you know like the native
sakharins and the chitauri especially
the chittari named the other who
literally walked around with a blindfold
because the universe of light was just
not for him he just was not about it and
this is why thanos was army was called
the black order because they were
essentially the dark universe's avengers
in this poisoned world of light
basically using thanos as a means to
eliminate as much light life as possible
even though thanos's goals didn't
necessarily align with theirs anyways
this is absolutely key to understanding
why doctor strange's spell was not able
to affect this black flubber of death at
the end of no way home because like
malekith and the dark elves the history
of the entirety of venom's race of alien
symbiotes from the planet kilntar
predates the stars themselves because in
the comics the story goes that the
symbiote race was originally created
from the primordial darkness before the
big bang by the primordial dark world
being known as no you know much like
malekith forged the reality stone aka
the ether from the primordial darkness
of the mcu and this being said since
symbiotes are beings made from that same
primordial darkness this means that
their physical bodies are composed of
dark matter unlike you and me who are
beings born from the light and thus are
composed of light matter dark matter for
example is the stuff that malaketh's
daggers and weapons and pretty much
everything that the dark elves used
because the only matter that existed in
the universe before the birth of light
matter was dark matter within the dark
nothingness of the ether void in fact we
could even see in thor the dark world
that the ether sucks the light out of
light matter to create dark matter that
essentially was malik's main goal to
blow the candle out on all the light
matter in the universe this makes sense
to use the ether because of the nature
of darkness absorbing light in the
universe naturally darkness absorbs
light and because of this absorptive
nature of dark matter in relation to
light this is why malekith's daggers can
effortlessly pierce korg's cronin skin
why corvus glaive's glaive can pierce
the vision's vibranium body and how
thanos was able to deflect light beams
with his thanos copter sword and even
destroy captain america's vibranium
shield this is all because these are all
dark matter objects breaking down light
matter easily because darkness absorbs
light and this is also why wanda's magic
is the only thing that was able to
destroy thanos sword in avengers and
game because his sword was made
primarily of dark matter it is this very
same absorptive relationship between
darkness and light that i believe that
is central to how symbiotes interact
with their human host self-decode is a
genetic testing and analysis company
that provides tools for new insights
into your health based on your dna you
get personalized health recommendations
based on your genome they're the only
company that offers truly personalized
recommendations based on your dna and
they don't sell your information to
anybody which is great because that's
your dna you don't want people making
clones of you and stuff
your results display your genetic risk
scores on a variety of health topics
from blood sugar to anxiety and then
give you a list of diet supplement and
lifestyle recommendations based on your
genes to help optimize your health you
can order a self-decor dna kit or upload
a dna file you already have to get your
results here at new rockstars producer
zach was really excited to get some
health recommendations so he took the
test and shipped the kit back to
self-decode and about six weeks later he
got back his results he got some great
supplement and diet recommendations to
improve his risk of high blood pressure
or inflammation problems and he was also
super excited to see that he was at the
lowest risk level for sexual dysfunction
hooray so build your own personal health
regimen and take the next step towards
optimal health check out the link in the
description and use code rockstars to
get 25 off self decode check out their
site and use the code rockstars to save
on self decode today very much like the
sentient ether sucking the life out of
jane foster and thor 2 the symbiotes in
the mcu are essentially dark matter
absorbing light matter energy
specifically the orange human soul
singularity energy that the asgardians
used their soul forged to detect this
dark world symbiosis within jane foster
and thor too it's a soul food does the
soul forge transfer molecular energy
from one place to another that is human
life force energy that is the most
important part of our bodies our soul
energy and this is why symbiotes burn
through humans so quickly in the venom
series they literally suck out all of
their bodies bioelectricity because
we've got all that tasty energy that
they need unless they find an actual
suitable match like your eddie brock's
or your peter parker's because this is
when the symbiotic part of the symbiote
comes in then this stronger human host
will then be given the energies and
powers of a dark matter being for their
soul energy you know just in case you
break your legs while trying to run away
from bad guys and venom one the reason
why the venom symbiote was left behind
at the end of no way home was because it
was entirely comprised of dark matter
outside of a light matter shell and dr
strange's ruins of cuff call spell only
applies to beings of light up until no
way home doctor strange has only been a
light universe magician who could only
manipulate light matter energy primarily
i mean he does use the time stone from
time to time until it was exploded which
is why the wizards of camertage
primarily operate using orange solar
soul singularity energy that lives
within every mcu human this is
essentially what all of eternals was
about this is about the powers of this
solar soul singularity the wizards of
comitage are just light beings using
light energy to protect everything the
light touches against the forces of
darkness mufasa style which makes sense
this means that the runes of kafka spell
a light spell cast by a light energy
user only applies to beings with light
matter physiology which means that the
only reason venom even came to the mcu
in the first place was because he
hitched a ride via his light matter
human host eddie brock a human whose
mind was connected to the collective
multiversal hivemind of the symbiote
race so it is only because one tom hardy
venom was inside eddie brock's light
matter body and two actively connected
to the symbiote hive bind at the time of
the spell's casting thus giving venom
the subconscious multiverse memory of
toby maguire's venom from the raimi
films that the venom symbiote was able
to hit a ride to the mcu however the key
here is that venom is situated inside of
eddie brock's body eddie brock is
venom's taxi across the multiverse if
let's say i don't know venom were to
drunkenly leave a little bit of dark
universe physiology on the bar when
doctor strange casts his runes of cough
call light magic spell a second time
then that little bit of dark matter
would have effectively missed its light
matter taxi outside of the mcu which is
exactly what happened and since it's now
stuck here it is now going to
instinctively go to its next best option
peter parker because the symbiote hive
mind now knows just how good radioactive
peter parker's taste and boy do those
awkward nerds taste like metaphorical
chit that is why i believe that the
venom symbiote was left behind at the
end of nowhere home what do you guys
think let us know in the comment section
below my beautiful nerd babies thank you
guys so much for watching this video
please follow me at mastertainment if
you want to see me tweet some weird
and some really interesting theories i
think but more importantly please follow
new rock charge wherever we are
especially on youtube where you can hit
that notification bell and get
notifications for every time we upload a
video and also be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com because we always got
the most amazing merch and things
available especially with peacemaker we
got this amazing peacemaker design that
you guys should check out because
peacemaker is an amazing show and james
gunn is the greatest man that ever lived
i'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you